to speak well you have to speak a lot
and you have to speak in intensive
situations hi steve kaufman here and
today i want to talk about
what is really
you know the fourth goal in my hierarchy
of goals
in language learning and that's speaking
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
and if you follow me on a podcast
service please leave a comment i do
appreciate it
so for many people speaking is the first
goal i want to speak
if you have followed me here you know
that
i have the view that is not realistic to
speak from day one let's say
if you're if you're in a situation like
my situation when i was in japan
where i'm surrounded by the language
i can try to speak to people
uh
but it won't be my major activity
initially because i i don't have the
words if you go back to my
hierarchy of goals i don't have the
words i haven't read these words i
haven't listened to enough of the
language so that i can understand i
don't have the listening comprehension
so my ability to talk to people is very
limited
so i am not that keen under normal
circumstances to start talking
i find it frustrating i find it
almost intimidating if i don't
understand what people are saying i'm
not so keen to engage them in
conversation so what are my goals
my goal
i i tend to say
you know i used to wait till i had about
10 000 words in a language before i
would start speaking to say a tutor
online
uh now i've dropped that to about
three to five thousand words
uh because i
maybe i've become better at learning
these languages
and so i don't mind the struggle
i'm less self-conscious about not
understanding
and in any case when i start with a
tutor i'll typically
get on there once or twice a week so
that's not a major investment of time
because where i want to continue to
invest my time
is listening and reading acquiring words
however i do recognize that to speak
well and we all want to speak well we
all want to speak well
um to speak well you have to speak a lot
and you have to speak in intensive
situations
so
to have a short conversation because
you're you go to someone in chinatown
and use a few words of chinese or you
order your
you know whatever dish in a chinese
restaurant in chinese to me that's not a
very
intense engagement with the language
on the other hand
if you are with people and you're
speaking chinese and you're with them
over dinner and everybody's speaking
chinese and you're speaking chinese and
you're participating in the conversation
that's tremendously powerful
that's first of all input
that is high resonance input because
you're in that conversation it's real
and you're struggling to get your
meaning out and there's a lot of
pressure because everyone's speaking
very quickly in chinese and when you go
to speak you feel you don't have the
time to say what you want to say
those are all great situations but to be
in that situation you have to have a
certain level of preparation so that's
why i put so much emphasis on acquiring
words reading to reinforce those words
listening to improve your listening
comprehension and then
when you get the opportunity try to put
yourself in intense
situations and when you're in that
intense situation just go for it
and
you know if you struggle to say what you
want to say if you feel that you you're
slowing down the conversation for
everyone else because that they're you
know
going to be impatient well mostly
they're not going to be impatient
they're willing to wait for you to say
what you want to say so i think it's
very important if if we have built up
our confidence in the language and our
comprehension if we have words we may
search for the words but somewhere we
know we have some of the words we want
to use if you have that level of
preparation you can get into
higher intensity
conversation opportunities it's a bit
like when i exercise now i'm doing these
kettlebell workouts high intensity
interval training
there's something to be said for high
intensity to be in a high intensive high
intensity
language situation
you have to be prepared for it
uh
just to sit like uh
and and talk about the weather
with five or six other
students it's not that it's not
effective but i think spending that time
with the language doing a lot of
listening and reading and and and
working on acquiring more words is a
more useful way to spend your time
and you can save that
speaking opportunity whether one-on-one
or in a group
till you have
sufficient
a sufficient vocabulary sufficient
confidence sufficient listening
comprehension so that you can actually
have a very intense even an hour
one-on-one now when i speak with my uh
persian tutor sahara we cover a lot of
ground and there's a lot of words that i
can't remember and she has to remind me
but
then i get from her my conversation
report on link where she has 15 or so
words and phrases that i didn't use
correctly or where i struggled or i'd
forgotten them
and and she records this and i listen to
it and i may forget it again for the
next time and in fact i can see
in my record of my conversation reports
going back say six months that i make
the same mistakes every week to a large
extent but gradually gradually gradually
i get better and so the
if i'm initially maybe only talking
twice a week i may eventually step that
up
particularly if i have an opportunity to
go to the country because when you go to
the country your opportunity to speak is
going to be much greater and i like to
prepare myself as much as possible
before going to the country so when i
went to greece or to romania then i
would beforehand step up the number of
conversations with my tutor to maybe
four times a week five times a week and
then
when i arrive in the country when i was
on crete i have a chance i have a chance
of understanding what they're saying i
have a chance that i can say what i want
to say and they won't come back at me
come back at me in english because
if you don't have that level then you
may miss you may not take full advantage
of the opportunity of being in the
country because the locals
who don't necessarily want to be your
teacher they just want to communicate if
they sense that you can't understand and
you can't communicate they'll switch to
a language where it's easier for them to
communicate which may be english so
i think it's very important to take full
advantage of that
you know speaking opportunity that
visiting the country can represent
to prepare for it ahead of time so
to summarize the goal in speaking
in my
view is
to get to a level where you can
defend yourself you don't have to be
perfect you can have poor pronunciation
you can forget words but you understand
what people are saying you can defend
yourself so you can hang in there hang
in there in these more intense
engagements with people in the language
which are going to be very powerful
for you to develop your speaking skills
which while i put it as the fourth goal
because i know there are three other
goals that have to come first but it is
a very important goal we all want to end
up speaking well so thank you for
listening i hope that was useful bye for
now